folks Chris waters here at san diego
comic con joined by anthony chow PR
director for phoenix rage phoenix rage
anthony uh it so the name conjures sort
of like red-eyed steaming and anger fury
but uh this is actually a very nimble
very fast-paced game yes yes yes it is
no it's uh it's kind of the devel- skies
green lava Studios Costa Rican guys they
were really inspired by like games like
sonic x sonic hedgehog and like super
meat boy so they really wanted to create
kind that old-school t2d action
platformer that will frustrate the heck
out of you and frustrate the heck out of
neck i say heck i say hell you could go
with you hell out of you there you know
oh my so I'm such passion so you are
this little character Phoenix yeah you
are just you know just your you're just
chilling at your village and all sudden
it's becomes frozen a horrible Cataclysm
these strikes down from the heavens and
you're just falling and yours kind of
chasing down this guy Octus who you
believe is you know responsible for this
okay um but you're grabbing cookies
along the way well yes because who
doesn't like cookies nobody doesn't like
thank you so what it's actually a cool
feature in the game where you collect
enough cookies you actually unlock
cooking recipes which are you well yeah
curable cookie recipes indeed cookie
recipes not a gameplay mechanic like you
call up the recipe and you make a cookie
in your house with ingredients that you
bought that that's not a gameplay
feature that sounds fair to you so I'm
hungry um what's what's really cool and
what's kind of evil about the main
designer gov Eduardo Ramirez entering
lava is he does he knew people were
really used to playing platformers like
Super Meat Boy style like you know wall
jumping and one not sure and Phoenix
doesn't have to do that you can just
totally just infinitely jump you can
infinitely dash side to side and whatnot
but when he designed this specific level
he wanted people to like think you can
wall jump and they had to and they had
to go back oh yeah and they were doing
that at it hacks and that III and he was
just in the background watch them just
evilly grinning at them like we like I
need news go straight exactly so yeah
it's it's it's it's um it's gets its
kind of a insight into the evil mind of
evil genius of Eduardo well it takes a
certain sinister pneus to design a
platformer like this that's you know
meant to challenge and meant to vex the
player and then in turn meant to like be
super rewarding once you complete it
exactly yes exactly so actually today
I'm going to show you who love us yes
nobody is we haven't seen you so at e3
we showed off both red forest and
crystal caves the next one is more sky
mm-hmm so I'll put a little cement
cinematic here now that's Phoenix and
that's all that's obvious the main text
messin with him now he is yes rule it
and throughout the game the mechanics
are will remain the same in this in a
sense that you all you have all your
kind of basic necessities intended to
beat the game which is like infinite
jobs and dashing yep what changes is
obviously the elements like turning on
fire and be able to like destroyed
blocks which are on fire it's like ice
block so who needs to show you all right
so you're smashing through little gravel
blocks then you're sliding down this
lava wall in order to get fire powered
em and you're going through these these
teleporters which you know paint
teleports you to paint the loot or what
is it how do they work anyway so you
just finish the level sorry that's fine
but these are these are these are the
little things that like build steadily
throughout the levels to just create a
much more and and which way and what's
the genius about and now she'll show you
here using the G word the genius of the
designer he basically ramps up the the
difficulty like like you wrap it up and
no go back down wrap it up and go back
down and then you feel like you're
really improving your skill set in terms
of dashing in terms of and you'll learn
other things like you can actually
cancel the dash back early by jumping oh
really yeah it's it's different like
play mechanics like that you eventually
learn AHA so and and it's it's quite and
you'll need to learn especially with
this Morse Cardinal you have to like
learn how like to like stop dash loops
like that's stopped falling and dying as
you will die
lot in this game already seeing some
dine here from you Anthony already uh
well thank you you know are you saying I
suck at this game to practice I did a
little bit I didn't know alright so the
monologues thanks guys the green is
obviously gonna kill you but the lava
you smash through ice blocks and then
this is just like sort of a little
teleport and not another mechanic here
is also so here this got to get the
other get through the ice blocks here
sure you can so instead so you can
actually just with getting shot and
didn't normally a projectile is
something you'd think like I probably
don't want to get hit but underlying a
lava rock exactly but you do actually in
this sense because his it's kind of the
role to character Phoenix is all about
fire the main bad guys all about nice so
it's fire and ice and now begin in the
yang mm-hmm and yeah it's these kind of
neat these and these I guess at level
mechanics um start building and building
and gets more and more difficult than
she goes with the game soon and so you
chose to not go get the cookie there but
like the cookie early on is sort of used
I think I was playing a few levels just
before we started it's used as a as sort
of a path indicator like go this way or
you know try scooping down around here
used your you know as sort of a just a
guide but then it switches and becomes
as it so often does that like challenge
get its heart it's much more hard to
cook what article 10 to finish the level
I'll tell you this everyone that's been
playing the game at e3 and packs they
always try to get the cookie at least
one time and then once i get the cook
and if they got a cookie the first time
we're in a kill and they get killed they
keep going after they keep going so yeah
yes it's it's definitely something that
they've been able to do it once yes and
no they can do it again taste of cocaine
they just won't defeat me and and you
know you see these levels and a lot of
it's like you know just move that fast
dashing and like pinpoint timing and but
there's also a lot of patients involved
here a lot of uh yeah actually this once
we get to that doesn't pretty train yeah
you're constantly jump in and keep
yourself from falling onto the
death bits and altering things Mayday
but there's also levels where the
requires just pure patients like this
one this one you're just basically just
tired your jobs and you know don't touch
the walls don't tell your garden the guy
Bob of you behind you and really are not
using this joystick at all no I'm doing
the edge Jack I'm just timing button in
rhythm yes exactly so do you have the
steely determination Anthony I do I
believe in you thank you no one else I
believe you can do it I can't I can't oh
no you've betrayed me high-pitched
Reagan you betrayed my trust in you and
of course a games like these they always
have bosses so this is the boss this is
one of our boss levels here okay and
it's it's it's it's you'll see just
bathe big blob and you have to basically
it comes right from underneath you whoa
so you're basically dodging us attacks
and you're basically just waiting to get
how using his attacks to open up the
pathway up here where go there you go
you
um the game is gone right there he'll
move up exactly now it's shots are a
little bit faster faster yes so say
again scaling difficulty for the user
and it's again I you know I I don't want
to say genius because one you know you
already said it I did but I don't want
to say genius because one is his first
game and two I don't want him to have a
huge you know big ego but it really is
like kind of very like the way he does
it is just so it's so cool and this kind
of game design definitely is sort of you
know these discrete sort of levels that
stand alone and these puzzle mechanics
just create a real fertile sort of
creative playground for a game designer
to put together the elements in
different ways yeah and in the corum
game mechanics and and the controls are
just just pixel perfect they're awesome
so it really just him playing around
with the levels and seeing how does
stage typical giving yes I'm sucked well
I know I also you know fortunately got
that instant restart which is so helpful
to like just one more just keep trying
that way in there exactly there's no
left low times or anything just know
right wah wah wah wah ah that was for
you thank you um coming out on pc on
xbox one yeah your place cool see now
and holding a xbox 360 360 controller so
this is you guys right I'm recommending
a controller play oh yes yeah I'm you
can there is a keyboard love set up but
you know I don't know how many people
actually play platformers action
platforms like this on a keyboard you
know set up so maybe you do oh no no no
do it so I mean why these play these
kind of games are difficult enough
without getting me into I feel like that
anyways probably playable with the
keyboard and mouse but optimized for the
controller yes very much so alright and
so sorry you were saying before it's
this is we're playing it on it's coming
out on Steam and xbox one ps4 fall 2014
we will have a properly announcing with
least eight fairly soon mm-hmm but yeah
and there's there's actually he's he's
Eduardo still playing around with the
different like kind of extra modes there
might be minigames there might be some
other stuff too as well besides the
young besides to cook the message
besides cookie rest well is he has he
playing around with the recipes I mean
are we getting some creative stuff here
we getting some Costa Rican delicacy use
Awards well we would you will have to
leave us I'll have to unlock yes exactly
this boss he's pissing me off sorry man
Anthony you were I don't even know how
far you were further than you were
before and you got vanquished this we
also showed off the throne or e3 demo
there's another boss he showed off that
was sort of a rolling that Eduardo was
here I'm showing off it's sort of a
rolling through the level metal boss so
the boss is a chance to mix up the
gameplay to really yeah use those
mechanics in but also have that
antagonist that's a different element
this boss my hero yes I am so basically
he's chasing you and you just had that
you know yes oops already oh you're in
trouble nope you are in trouble Anthony
chow and this is not good I think okay
already okay I think I don't know okay
one more time yeah not terrible what do
you what's this little bird what are
these little birds flying out of the way
uh well these birds actually are your
friends and they're giving you kind of
key like for example so here I'll show
you it's like so these you see the bird
the line right there if you land right
there and you dash through Oh kind of
like a very subtle hint system he like
lines you up I see ya so I mean there
are they're helpful in that sense but
for the most part you have to still have
the skills to should yeah just one more
time that's why that that's what if we
Mo's gonna be 37 minutes long as you try
to beat this is this wow yeah is that a
challenge I got issued have you thrown
down the guy I don't like that I don't
want to sit here for 37 minutes i'm
watching you play the same level but I
will if that's what it takes you
one more time one more time come on ciao
I'm I know you called time by last name
so you could buy my last name and your
nice like getting me angry i'm laying
down the gullet morning well maybe you
need a little bit let's really get you
through here because this is upcoming
part you need a lot to do this oh and
he's that's yet digit good all right ah
that's phoenix rage Anthony chow rage
it's what we just hub that's coming out
this fall steam xbox one and ps4 be sure
to keep an eye out for release date news
on gamespot com as Phoenix rages release
date approaches
you